good morning millennium happy Friday
millenials happy dirty jeans to our
launch day excuse me for being on my
phone for one second I'm just making
sure that everything is going as
smoothly as possible
for the toasters that I love and adore
happy Friday we did it we did honestly
this is the first time we've had a full
week like with both of us and so long
and honestly I thought I hated traveling
so much and like you know having long
weekends working weekends like five days
a week at work is hard yeah everyone
else but finally I think it depends on
who you ask cause personally I would
rather be home like than be traveling so
either this torture than the Vegas
torture no totally I mean when I like
have to do like shows during the week or
like leave early and do shows during the
weekend like it is torture like I love
doing shows and I love seeing everyone
but like working when you blur the lines
between work and like free time it's a
dangerous thing because then it's all
just fair game it's like no one even
cares to ask you for a meeting on a
Saturday you do a show on a Saturday I
agree well you know what I'm gonna be
honest I'm really here I read a negative
podcast review about us that we complain
too much and now listening to us like I
don't find that oh I know so now that
say one positive thing about our week
we're alive the dirty jeans tour went on
sale everyone is healthy knock on wood
and there's so much to be grateful
there's so much Jewish people the person
who wrote that review obviously it's not
Jewish yeah and they don't understand
that just complaining is a part of
conversation yeah and it's like it's a
way of life it really is it's a thing
you should read up on it it's big and
you know but I've been realizing this
week in specifically like in
specifically this week specifically like
how much we do complain and like it's
probably annoying for people to listen
to so I'm just gonna be aware of it like
first to be any other week we're up late
complaining about how sick we were then
we were complaining about our time
everywhere now we're complaining just
about work like remember when nobody
wanted to work with us like let's be
grateful yeah let's be grateful um yeah
and he's been like after what we said
yesterday on the show about complaining
about being ugly a lot of people that
really resonated with a lot of people
there's something in the air time of
year I had the most I couldn't sleep
last night I was dealing with Becca
Tilley and she was like I go through
this all the time I'm like Liberty my
hair feels like straw and I was telling
I'm like I think I tried to make myself
feel better by getting lip injections
like now I just feel stupid and she's
like oh
no I totally understand like the fact
that like literally the most beautiful
girl in the world understood I was like
okay maybe I am the most beautiful girl
in the world right or like it's just
there's some it is a season I think also
talking about it made me feel better
like actually I'm feeling good today
great yeah I'm looking good today I'm
feeling good just cuz like dirty jeans
sales are through the roof everyone's
like so pleased and I'm so pleased and
it's just it's a good day that's great
and it's Friday well how could I not be
there people who might be their first
show where can everyone get their
tickets to the dirty jeans store so it's
10:00 a.m. in New York and that means
all the Eastern Standard Time shows have
just went on sale so that including you
let me get on my list because time is
not my thing I have a lot of talents
Jackie and let me tell you that time
zones are not one of them so at 10 a.m.
30 minutes ago Pittsburgh went on sale
Philadelphia went on sale Lexington
Kentucky Charleston Toronto Richmond
Virginia Virginia Beach and Asbury Park
New Jersey those are all on sale go to
girl with no job calm or my Instagram
highlights takapa ticket there they're
flying next up in 26 minutes is the
central time shows and in case you don't
know central time like myself it's the
following shows Minneapolis Minnesota
Austin Texas
Minnesota Chicago we added a second show
because the crazy toasters sold it out
in presale never heard of that Chicago
Milwaukee Wisconsin and New Orleans
Louisiana and I know you said you're
coming to NOLA because we are getting
lit so that's in 30 minutes head over to
girls no job comm or my instruments
Tori's for the links and then in Pacific
time which is one o'clock here but 10
a.m. Pacific time Las Vegas Nevada Los
Angeles
hit me up San Diego San Francisco
Seattle Vancouver and Portland so then
that's like the majority of a ton and
then a special time noon in New York The
Beacon Theater goes on sale I wanted to
give it its own timeslot like so it
didn't fall through the cracks cuz like
and so that you wouldn't be on the show
while it's ready so I'm gonna be on the
show during Central Time so just like
make sure to remind me let me just
prepare my Instagram caption like you
could talk about something so if you're
watching from Central Time you just know
you can hop off or you know if you have
a split screen situation phone or phone
works you can just hop off buy your
ticket and come back and we'll still be
here talking about probably nothing
we're a lot we have some well-rounded
stories today actually it's been a
well-rounded week it's been a really
well-rounded weaken a nice mix of celeb
nice mix of stories that like might come
up at a dinner table conversation and we
have one story today
that is the story that people are gonna
be talking about and I'm I don't have
like so many thoughts on it because I'm
not like an antitrust expert but um just
want you all to be well-versed and
what's going on in the world of Facebook
and government you know the government
they're meeting all the time these days
Facebook and government oh my god
totally like those memes of Mark
Zuckerberg in the Supreme Court by the
way he recorded a great patriotic
message yesterday with jaunt Argan who
just launched his new fashion line fall
risk and we did a Met Gala extravaganza
fashion breakdown with John and like
having his expertise really added uh
gravitas and he explained a little bit
more of camp to me and it wasn't the
description I had come up with in my
mind it was like a little bit more
satirical I'm so it was interesting to
have like a perspective of someone who
actually knows Stefan doesn't talk out
of their ass like me right it was super
interesting so if you want to listen to
a patriot act patreon.com slash the
morning toast it's a great place to be
and we were intending on doing half the
episode with Fashion Police and half the
episode with Met Gala blinds from nt but
we just got so wrapped up in the fashion
of it I wouldn't have any time so our
second episode is gonna be an in-depth
deep dive on the blinds from the Met
Gala because apparently there are a
bunch yeah exciting super exciting some
I hadn't aside from like blinds I
haven't really like read any stories
about like what was going on in the
bathroom no cuz you want to know why
they've really cracked down on cell
phone like it used to be like you could
take cell phone pictures in the mirror
of the bathroom but now it's no cell
phones in the bathroom too but people
were like Instagram storing the
performances so lately yeah I saw so
many of them in like Harry Styles
talking and Lady gaga talking so I don't
know I didn't see that I saw some people
were like sending me stuff so then all
of a sudden watching like some stylists
Instagram story and you're looking very
Umbra today thanks you know I just um I
I guess it's the changing of the weather
it hurt me confused on what to wear
because I'll dress for spring and then
it's cold and then I'll okay so it's
winter like maybe I wear tights and then
I look stupid and it's warm so today I
was just like I'm gonna be comfortable
and they went to go to my sweatshirt
section and then I saw this one and then
it works with the boots that I just
found in the move because I lost them in
my old apartment because it was just
like the Bermuda Triangle I got a little
ahead of myself this week you know to
rompers in a row shorts lead no legs
[ __ ] freezing I was out walking Theo
like my nose was running I felt like an
idiot
oh and my I'm sneezing all over the
place nephew sneeze Ches nephews sneeze
Ches how is the precious gem of a man
the precious gem of man Marga made such
a great call ever since we started
leaving him like when I used to leave
for for work I would leave him in the
crate because that was like his safe
space to be crate trained to him but
once he turns a certain age you're
supposed to let them have a little bit
more freedom and like stay in an
isolated room instead of the crate so
we've been leaving him out and about in
the living room dining room area and he
has just been loving it some days he
ends up in his crate and which makes me
realize he's such a good boy and
sometimes he just like sleeps in the
corner of the couch and it's so cute but
he just gets home now we get home now
he's just like roaming around Margot's
like he's literally a cat oh my god he's
because he just like climbs up on the
couch and like just ventures out looking
for stuff but he's also so independent
cuz it's like he spends more time in the
house and you guys do and so it's kind
of his home he knows my house better
than I do
yeah he knows what's going on like he
should be in contact with your
superintendent he knows where the bodies
are buried
he really does he's the house manager
well speaking of the precious gem I have
a really exciting announcement that
we'll be launching next week um just so
if you want to be inspired by like CEOs
Instagram flow that might like get you
excited about what's coming this is good
segue almost as good was one of our ads
segues oh yeah well you figure
technically well speaking of CEO don't
you ever just want to remember like
everything that he's doing and I
actually looked at a picture from
yesterday and he looks like so mature
and then I was thinking of when we first
got him he really looks so different a
different face and I remember when they
first sent us a picture
we got him as we saw like his baby
picture and then once he was on his way
to New York the guy travelling with him
sent a picture of his face and like it
looked a little weird like hit a huge
head and me a member looking any other
were like did we get like an ugly dog
and good thing and ended up being
literally the most beautiful precious
delicious me superstitious nutritious
dog on planet earth well luckily you've
only had two CEO in the digital age but
for some of us we have photos and videos
from the days of the veal or from the
days of yore and luckily legacy box is
here to bring those memories back to
life truly so I love legacy box me of
all these home videos we used to be so
[ __ ] extra like we used to spend like
Sunday's like converting our VHS to DVD
and like Julie was such like a process
and it's got all these expensive like
adapters but we would watch it and like
it was worth like the three minutes of
blurry video just for like that
nostalgic vibe because we used to like
literally put on performances like in
our living room to Spice Girls like we
used to do the morning toast everyday
but just like kids who couldn't talk and
just would dance it was an interpretive
dance there was obviously like a
breakout star in terms of vocally and
you know it's tough for Olivia you could
see it in the video so home videos like
Olivia's feeling like a little you know
threatened by my talent but you know at
such a young age who wouldn't be
threatened by my dad so if you want to
watch your siblings be threatened by
your talent or be thirsty
send your legacy box filled with old
home movies and pictures legacy box will
do the rest professionally digitizing
your moments onto a thumb drive digital
download or DVD there's never been a
better time to digitally preserve your
memories visit legacy voxcom
today to get started plus for a limited
time they're offering our listeners an
exclusive discount go to some legacy
box.com
slash toasts to get 40% off your first
order go to legacy by legacy box.com
slash tous and save 40% today get
started preserving your past whatever we
read for legacy box I always think of
that thing Mark Cuban says like when
there's a brand that comes on he's like
you don't solve a problem like a brand
meets and this was like a huge [ __ ]
problem that like nobody solved for
years yeah and they made it really easy
cuz like not only yeah it's nice to be
able to like send your things in but
then it's like okay I have to go get a
box right they send you the empty box
too no totally boxes are I've become
like true like every time we get at
Amazon box it like boxes I'm almost like
a recycling environmental Queen because
I'm constantly using my boxes
it's so hard to find a box these days
that's a great call you know okay
are you ready to get into the fast 5
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast I guess yeah I think that
you are you look like you are yeah no I
definitely look like someone who's ready
for food ok our first story Taylor Swift
is on the cover of Entertainment Weekly
in a jacket that is covered with clues
about her new album yes we're gonna put
a picture of her on the cover on the
stream so you can see her and her pins
and let's talk about some of the ones
that really stand out to you ok
obviously Doug done which is the Law &
Order nod I don't know that that's
necessarily an easter egg because I
think the buttons were supposed to be
this is my personality that's all so
we're gonna board yeah boys so the the
cat ones I think the Sansa and Arya ones
were just personality things even though
you can't help but think about the Jojo
deserve it all her ex man has a new
girlfriend how how mature is she like
that I feel like there are a lot of
people that tell us about harbors
resentment over in terms of
relationships but Joe Jonas is not one
of them okay well okay because she
[ __ ] beat that dead horse like
through and through by the way I have
been recently doing a lot of
Investigatory information on that entire
saga and I knew that there was more to
the story than I once knew and here's
what it is
because in my opinion and before I knew
a lot of the story better than revenge
was the only song I wasn't like
completely on board with in terms of a
song it's a great song but if you don't
know the backstory Joe Jonas broke up
with Taylor Swift on the phone in a 26
second phone call and she like blasted
him I'm like this Today Show and he
started dating camilla belle like right
after and Taylor Swift wrote a song
called better than revenge which is like
you are with this girl who thinks she's
so great and predator peppy and like I
there's nothing I do better than revenge
so she better watch out and like no man
in vintage dresses will give her dignity
which is like the prevision of no matter
how many Chanel bags you borrow you will
never be a lady and so I was like you
know what I thought that song like was a
little caddy if her just because like it
was unprompted like yes you can be mad
that Joe Jonas broke up with you but at
the end of the day like it's not Camilla
bells fault right then it's like you
were like here's the missing piece of
information that nobody knows do you
know that the Jonas Brothers wrote the
song first called much better it's
called she's much better you can Adam
nah I'm done dating superstars
no more teardrops on her guitar like it
was very obviously about Taylor's band
have these new girls so much better much
better
that's my Taylor Schmidt was like cuz
you're so much better I think you know
what you came for Taylor stop everyone
like just villainizing Taylor like that
song was so catty that's what I would I
believed a villian ization
they came to her first and they wrote a
mean song about her stop writing these
songs that Taylor I'm eating stop
writing mean songs about you so I'm okay
so back to the pits sorry so some of
them are just like purely personality
things like the friends pins all the six
characters in the corner Sansa and Arya
Meredith okay that's the friends pins
what do you think that means there's so
many
no I just think those are the six
characters like I don't think it has
anything to do with the album no okay so
what do you think so there's one of her
and Selena Gomez and I think her and
Selena Gomez are gonna be doing a
collaboration especially because the
picture of Selena Gomez is from an
interview where she would was asked if
she would ever collaborate with Taylor
Swift so definitely that's easy dun dun
there's a picture of Faith Hill would
love some country collab collab and
Faith Hill posted the pins so like maybe
there's something there okay also
there's one that says the Dixie Chicks
which is now the second reference
there's no doubt in my mind there is a
Dixie Chicks Club which only makes me so
[ __ ] excited cuz then you think there
maybe country-by-country bag okay but we
have Sansa Arya and then we also have
Daenerys and a dragon so like that's
more than just like a game of Thrones
mood well actually in the entertain
actually no it's not and did you read
the Entertainment Weekly interview its
pieces she said that reputation was like
so heavily influenced by Game of Thrones
like when she read word I did something
bad it was when Arya like did something
bad like she was with like a lot of the
songs are like so heavily influenced by
human Thrones so like she spoke about
that in the interview so them being on
the jacket doesn't make me think it's a
clue but that's a reputa
thing like that's a reputation thing I
feel like if she's doing it again these
are just like her the new ear this is
the cover no I don't think they're all
clues that's what I'm saying
so there's another clue on there you see
you see the little orange one with like
five blue graffiti writing that is the
background of the delicate music video
where she's like dancing through the
subway in LA it says track five like on
the subway track with people now she's
made like her the fifth track on her
album like a whole thing so this is like
another nod to the delicate music video
to track five like the fifth when she
was posting clothes the fifth clothes
she posted was the one with the fence
which I could show people like drove
people insane because it was so
confusing like we never got any
clarification on what it actually meant
so track five is like this ominous sort
of a moment for Taylor Swift but here's
where I'm at okay but there's also mr.
Rogers and now I'm seeing there's
actually two Daenerys is and Dragons
there's this that's a picture of
Daenerys and Dragons and then there's
Daenerys and a dragon above her that's a
lot of symbolism it is for just a vibe
and Drake is on there too so the Drake
one is one that I find most interesting
okay because now I'm firmly in belief of
a theory that I read on tumblr that this
is a double album because Drake just won
all these awards for his double album
Drake's on the thing
Herman Drake her and Drake have like a
good relationship they did those Apple
TV Apple commercial supplement
commercials but more importantly she
said in this interview that this album
has more songs on it than she's ever had
she's like I was just reading so much
and they may want to take stuff away so
it's like okay you're doing a double
album okay I'm here for that yeah over
there er that cuz maybe we could get
like side one pop aside to country oh so
now people think okay cuz when when she
sent out merch for me it says like it's
like a fake CD of me I'm sorry well my
phone has never been on there's a fake
CD of me and it says number and Opie
read ones me Genson people think it's
like the first side of the track and
that the second side of the track would
be you so this is a theory that's
floating around I'm here for it I'm
excited I would love to get like a date
on ts7 you know get it all really the
name like it the ball wasn't quiet for a
while I think it's time to get the ball
rolling I too would like if a ball would
start moving yeah just like so we have
things like you know till if I were two
milestones you know she said something
in an interview I was reading like her
old 3430 interview in a magazine anyway
I loved that because you know what she's
still right about so many things your
hair changes I've literally realized
that this week when you grow older your
hair changes texture she's like you know
what I would do for my curls literally
same totally one thing that she said
though that at the time I was like lame
and that now I'm like thinking it's a
really great idea is like she said in
order to like start you know just like
any like you know just being a positive
person she downloaded like these
countdown apps and like would put all
these things that she's excited about
and have like countdowns for everything
and now that's what she's doing with her
album obviously but it made me think I
kind of want to just putting counted on
to the concert said I'm going it's like
a planer till I get excited for like I
feel like after you get married it's
like oh you have this big thing that you
were looking forward to and now
everything else just like pales in
comparison but no I'm looking forward to
camp toes I'm looking forward to my
college reading and weekend I'm looking
forward to Rascal Flatts at PNC like I'm
expecting taking Molly
I told me when we were a coach and we
saw all these people on drugs and we
were like talking about Lauren Elizabeth
they're like if you had to take Molly
like and get so legs snow festival in
concert and there would be no negative
side effects so just like Molly where
you're rolling face here you're part of
that you take the rolled face so I don't
know the concert will be like five hours
and they'll only because it like what
music what artists would you want to
like leave it on the dance floor and
Jackie was very honest she said Rascal
Flatts and you know I think that's a
fantastic answer I
I think either like Taylor Swift or Luke
combs yeah but both I feel like for
Taylor you would want to be like why you
want to be an observer you know I would
need to like be present yeah so I don't
think that's limit it's just where you
just want to get lost in music for me
it's sagging Rascal Flatts it's so funny
cuz like most people are H I get lit in
like and like get lost
in beats and like Avicii but like I
truly get lost in like Tim McGraw no I
get lesson like the bass guitar yes Oh
behind me in the page hello you've got a
role to the game Luke Holmes he released
a song on Wednesday but it's me music
Friday you're never broke my heart and
it's a [ __ ] banger you know what's so
interesting about that song Margeaux
like knew the words when he played it at
stagecoach because an interesting
marketing tactic is he's been playing it
on tour now it's also the name of his
tour yeah but but that doesn't mean you
know the song but he's been playing the
song for like a year and then I had a
realization because you know I have
amnesia remember when we saw Luke Holmes
at CMA fest we were like a new fans of
his but we knew a bunch of his songs and
like I really fell in love with him at
that performance and I remember there
was a song that I loved it was like a he
was like a metaphor about beer and I
remember going on my snapchat at the
time and being like oh man I love Luke
um is he saying this song that I just
loved I wish I remember the words it was
something about a beer
like and and love I don't know and every
wasn't out at the time so everyone's
like it's beer can which is a song that
he has which was a metaphor about beer
nothing picks me up like a beer can so
that was like I thought the song and now
I realized in hindsight that was the
song I was referring to yeah I loved it
when I heard it when I wasn't even a
huge fan of his and now did you see the
music video it's so [ __ ] cute oh my
god no I haven't seen it yet but also I
think she played it when we were on MSG
cuz when you played it at siege it
didn't feel like the first time I had
heard it no but I think because one of
those songs to that it's like you were
this only existed before it came out
right yeah it's just like it's we've
been waiting for this song so everyone
go check it out also ed Sheeran and
Justin Bieber released the song today it
got leaked it got leaked last night I
didn't listen to the nene leakes version
but I did listen this morning and I
really enjoyed it however the premise of
the song where I like up until the
chorus so those are the only lyrics I
really like listen to it but I haven't
heard any of it I don't know those are
the lyrics like I pay attention to you
before I forget that I'm listening to
the source which is a great place to eat
is they talk about like being at a party
and like being an outsider and like not
fitting in and it's like you're ed
Sheeran and Justin Bieber like it's your
party no wait if Ed Sheeran released a
song
could see I'd shared feeling like an
outsider maybe it was about back in the
day before he was a major yeah but it's
like Ed Sheeran if your own to a party
with Justin Bieber like you're fine
right you know doesn't mean like if
you're at a party like it's probably
your own party Margaux is like it's so
upset up in arms and the song came out
the same day week as Lou Combs cuz she's
like they're gonna steal the number one
spot from Luke legate serves that Margit
was like so invested in the marketing
pie Luke owns his career like she has
got to chill out totally but the song
that chair and song you just to me for
something is really good mark was such a
passionate fan like if I was a singer I
would want Margo to be my number one fan
like the leader of my fan club or you
because like you're just right or go
that's true I'm very writer try but
Margo is more like actively like
engagement Margot will stay up till
midnight to hear the new song where's
like I'll go to sleep and then it'll be
the first thing I listen to in the
morning yeah she's like a crazy Stan
that's really true she's always staying
up until midnight to listen to the new
song and then it's on her story like
while everyone else is asleep but it's
also like a lifestyle thing because like
she does stay up till midnight where
like I very rarely on a weeknight will
go to bed before after midnight
yesterday I just had to end the day so I
went to bed like [ __ ] 9 o'clock a
newman's me like 11 oh I went to bed at
10:00 but I was watching that new
Netflix show dead to me I heard it so
good okay I had no clue what is about I
felt like the first sentence of the of
the description where it's like two best
friends getting over a grief and so I
thought it was one thing and it's a
complete other thing and just with each
episode I'm like what show him what is
this show I can't even categorize it
like I don't want I think you should I
want you to watch it in the same way
that I did where it's just like what is
this show I just love Christina
Applegate like ever since don't tell Mom
the babysitter's said I have been like a
ride-or-die
the sweetest thing like oh and then
Linda Cardellini chutney right no
Christina Applegate they're both in it
let's Linda Cardellini and Christina
Applegate who's who does Christina
Applegate play Legally Blonde Linda
Cardellini plays chutney and who does Oh
was Linda Cardellini in dead to me yeah
oh sorry I totally I thought okay I
totally misinterpreted that entire
conversation um yeah but no I actually
like for some reason despise Linda
Cardellini and it's be show won't make
it any better it's because she acted so
good as chutney that I will never see
her as the murdering stepsister daughter
right and she also like had an affair
with Don Draper on Mad Men so for that
reason and then she was also like the
like eggs
teenager in Freaks and Geeks who like
had such a nice family and like a nice
house and like hedges a very like
blessed life and she was always angry
about something and I'm like look you
have the nicest parents like and they
cook you dinner every night like chill
the [ __ ] out totally like you know what
it was on that show - yeah you don't
know what it's like to like not have
dinner waiting for you
I know until you grow up no totally and
it's just like she Linden looks like
rich neighborhood I went to this nice
school and she was like a smart and she
was pretty like and James Franco like
was into her like she was such a little
engrained in that show I went to kill
her yeah well you should watch shed to
me I'd be curious to hear your thoughts
everybody suggested it and it's been a
while since I got into a new show yeah
it's dangerous and like I was just
interested and do would you say it's
full of interesting factoids and how did
you find them to be I didn't find them
to be well interesting I'm not gonna lie
that's the thing about interesting
factoids they're interesting next
interesting factoid Kim Kardashian and
Kanye West surrogate has gone into labor
here comes the baby Kanye West and Kim
Kardashian are about to welcome their
fourth child together as their surrogate
went into labor Thursday night Kourtney
Kardashian announced on Ellen Kris
doesn't even know this but Kim Suri it
went into labor so she's at the hospital
the baby will join North st. and Chicago
as Kimmy's fourth child so sweet
exciting cute can't wait for all of it
baby name projections it's a big week
for baby except it is a big week for
babies except I am curious who or what
body Ellen and a Kardashian buried
together that literally the Kardashians
like give her everything like this was
the thirstiest announcement ever like
Christmas on milik we have a surprise
for you
Kourtney's here with six your egg heads
and like when he comes out it like with
all the kids like a babysitter and then
they sit down she's like mom you don't
even know this like Kim sir quick Kris
is like but so thirsty like Ellen just
like raking in the views on her Ellen
Tube channel and I just want to know but
after Kim's robbery she went on Ellen
like why do they have this Allegiance
with Ellen especially when they have
this enews relationship you know yeah I
have no idea
it's so weird and like so they're seeing
like it's so not that like doing daytime
you know yeah or like planned things
like this like for them everything just
like mix and then they they figure I
guess it's like nice to have somewhere
to you know make your announcements but
why like why now why this we have a
hundred million followers like that's
your platform you know
yeah okay baby name predictions I saw
one in the toasters that said free and I
really liked it cuz like the meaning
behind kima's like getting more legal
now she's freeing people from jail it's
also like a nice like free spirit like
celebrity name so I think that's a
really good guess I think that's a
really good cause
obviously you know everyone's still
guessing wild and East no she said
she'll never do another direction people
are saying that it has to do something
with her dad so like Rob or George but
it's not gonna I don't think it's gonna
be Robin they they do like the four four
letters who said that I forget North is
five yeah North is right yeah never mind
I thought that but I do think one
syllable I thought they were going for
one syllable which is why they call
Chicago shy yeah um like shine North
saying oh and the fourth one um
yeah free is actually a really good
guess but I understand why she would you
like a Robert or George but it's also a
regular name so she definitely wouldn't
do it
now imagine if you have Chicago North
st. George no yeah especially if it's
the last one like you end it you could
have snuck it in with a third kid like
you know like see North George
Chicago yeah yeah at the end it's like
too flat I'm excited I'm excited to me
the season was good it's like it's just
so exciting I'm so happy for her she has
so much joy she is so much joy and like
I'd like to think five years ago like do
we ever think when Kim like just
randomly got pregnant with North and she
was like had a boyfriend at the time
like that she would end up being just
like the mother of our generation like
for kids like literally all she does is
via mom like and it's so funny cause
Kourtney has branded herself was like
the mom but just watching Kardashian's I
feel like I know the dynamics and I
really feel like Kim prioritizes like
being a mom literally over everything
but still manages to be incredibly
subdue a million other things right
where's Kourtney prioritizes it and like
has nannies pick up the kids from school
right interesting well some more baby
news because bachelor in paradise alums
Carly wood Ellen Evan bass are expecting
baby number two you know what's so funny
about them is how your opinions can
really change on people and what's so
funny about them is how the proof is in
the pudding right so my opinion of them
was just like so negative because I
thought the way that she's treated her
my paradise was like horrible I'm like
how could you ever love and like share a
family with someone who said like these
incredibly mean things
you in public but for some reason like I
kind of think they're really cute they
are really can then it's a crime hard to
be anything other than like they're
weird selves right and you know two
people can come off a paradise engage
blah blah blah and it's like it doesn't
really mean anything until like you put
in the mileage and you get married do
you get married or you just say age do
you have children
do you like and they're just living
their life and they don't care about
what what happened and like they're
never tried I feel like I've every
trying to prove something to us they're
letting their lives to do the talking I
totally agree I like they have just like
a really happy life yeah I feel like
that too and they also have King Charles
Cavalier spaniels which means that they
they they know what it means to have a
precious gem and they know but the true
meaning of family is and the true
meaning of tastes totally yes so I'm
really happy for them um it's just a so
many babies is always good for the
bachelor yes - couple has a baby because
it's like okay maybe we do a lot of
fucked-up things and this show is like
inherently misogynistic backwards etc
but we have created life well how many
other shows can say that how can you
argue with that no okay I want to talk
about something since we're talking
about baby news Amy Schumer you know she
gave birth yes and she said the name of
her may be on Instagram and I I'm almost
positive it's a joke no okay because she
said the kid's name is gene middle name
Attell last name Fisher which is genital
Fisher
she's like a hemorrhoid so I think like
the joke really went over a lot of
people's heads but I'm almost positive
it's joke oh I was just soldier until I
saw that someone posted a tweet in the
toaster saying like I can't believe like
I don't know if they were being mean or
they they really figured out the joke
had its Schendel I think they figured it
out and the Michelle wolf left a comment
like that was like funny name or
something like I I'm pretty sure it's a
joke but I feel like I don't want to say
to joke in case it's like the kids real
name because like Gina's a normal name
but like I tell Fisher I don't know
right so genital also like when Kim
announced at North was the name of North
like a hunch percent thought it was a
joke I was like they are laughing all
the way to the bank but what's so crazy
is like now I just think it's a normal
you know but like I was like on this
like I really thought it was a joke like
until it was like three months later I
was like okay guys I guess we're
sticking with North and I love it ya
know and it's just crazy how like
time heals all wounds you know yeah I'm
like relatively sure it's a joke I just
am NOT 100 percentage okay I'm gonna go
and say I don't think it's a joke I
think it's a joke
let me tell you what Michelle wolf I
watch it I can't cuz I need to leave
this actually again no interesting
because both of us lost the Megan and
Harry bet yeah so now this is a 50/50 to
like one of us is right one of us is
wrong the other pays the other ten
dollars okay let me tell you Michelle
wolf left to cover their so many
comments on this picture oh my god maybe
she was just rake it in the engagement
these days okay let me find Michelle
Wells comic because it was quite telling
so many celebrities left comments on her
Instagram like Oh Michelle oh it's so a
joke she wrote Gina Ted Fisher and his
dad Chris and Michelle wolf were already
so much like a tell it's when I
presented joke I know I don't I think it
has to be addressed I think that would
be like such an interesting time to to
throw out a joke no that's why I like
Amy Schumer is truly like alleged like
yeah that's so funny
also the back that she stopped at the
Met Gala red carpet on her way to the
hospital my god I saw that that was that
Schumer that like I love and of course
that she gave birth on the same week as
Megan Marco but her special she was
complaining about how difficult it is to
be pregnant as a sit at the same time as
Megan Marco yeah okay you know what I'm
hot I look forward to finding out how
this story and I I really think it's a
joke like I I'm almost positive
oh it's 11 o'clock Central Time shows
just went on sale
that's Minneapolis Milwaukee Chicago
second show added cuz the toes are sold
it out Austin Texas and New Orleans so
had two girls no job calm or Meghan
scrim stories by whoo and then come back
next story Wendy Williams slams women
who cheat with married men in the wake
of her divorce okay so this story is a
bit of a two perks it's Wendy Williams
talking about another story that you and
I spoke about in the car but we haven't
spoken out on the show which is Ayesha
curry on read Table Talk I'm gonna take
it from the top because this is Incept
this is story ception
because it's stories within stories
Wendy Williams did not hold back when it
came to her opinion about women who try
to seduce Mara
men amid reports that her own estranged
husband Kevin hunter allegedly cheated
on her on Thursdays taping of the Wendy
Williams Show the host discussed Ayesha
curries frustrations over women who have
tried to cross boundaries with her
husband Steph Curry
even while Aisha is standing right next
to them quote there are a lot of women
with no respect for a marriage Williams
said before pausing you know what I'm
saying a lot of women who know your man
is married and will have the nerve to be
right up under him right under your nose
Williams went on to share a snippet of
Ayesha's interview with Jada Pinkett
Smith on read Table Talk where she
recounted an incident in which a fan
will cross the line with her I'll never
forget Aisha says in the clip we wanted
to buy bikes one day Riley at the time
she's less than a year old and this
group of people come over there trying
to ask sefar pictures and autographs the
woman opens the car door sticks her body
in the car and is just like oh let me
see oh and I'm like no no get out of the
car and she goes oh honey you know what
you signed up for
Williams quickly shared her opinions on
such women quote for you long for you
lonely girls who can't keep their hands
off other people's men there's a hot
place in hell for you
the daytime host said great Williams
added that men in these situations have
a lot more to lose than the women
flinging themselves at them agreed I
mean where Aisha Korean Wendy Williams
agree I agree as well women who have no
respect for married men even literally
in front of the wives like there's a
special place in hell like you're insane
and I think pretty much everyone in the
world would agree with that
yeah but what Wendy Williams didn't talk
about from this interview was perhaps
the more interesting part where I you
shook her II and I'm just paraphrasing
here said quite possibly one of the
weirdest things I think maybe I've ever
heard for a million reasons so she was a
find the director well you find it
because I don't maybe I don't want a
paraphrase but maybe in the meantime I
should tell you that I'm reading the
comments on YouTube and I am now almost
a hundred percent sure that Amy Schumer
was not joking oh my god because a tel
is a comedian who was her mentor it's
like the name may be his first or last
name so Dave Attell Amy's mentor baby
name not a joke Dave Attell is a famous
stand-up comic oh okay we'll see I you
should hurry said well it's something
that really bothers me and has given me
a sense of an insecurity yeah there are
all these women throwing themselves but
me I don't have any of that
I have zero male attention and I begin
to internalize
like is something wrong with me I'm like
that's not fair I don't want it but it
would be nice to know that someone's
looking that is the quote and apparently
there has been a lot of backlash about
it I haven't see what she says is that
people like throw themselves at her
husband and like she gets that it's a
part of the lifestyle or whatever but
instead of being in addition to being
angry about women flinging themselves at
him she's also angry that she doesn't
get the same attention to and I'm going
to say this in the nicest way possible
like I need her to know that mmm
women aren't fleeing themselves at Steph
Curry because he's the hottest man alive
because he's rich and famous like he is
like an accomplished athlete a respected
person in the sports world like and he's
famous like she is Steph Curry's wife so
it's like first of all no man would it
literally ever cross Steph Curry the
most respected athlete in the world and
like I'm not trying to be harsh but it's
like you're you yourself are not really
on your own like a famous or famous for
something other than being stuff great
swype so like and then she's part of a
beating Steph Curry's wife it needs to
be career and she has a show but no
stars and thing Steph Curry's wife so I
just I mean I really I - I'm trying not
to me like rude but I totally get not
that I agree with it I completely
understand how and why women fling
themselves at Steph Curry and if you
told me that men were falling on their
over their feet to go Taisha create it
wouldn't make any sense because one one
men in their right mind would have
literally ever get caught with the
greatest basketball player arguably of
all times why so I guess the argument
would be okay there the men don't want
to cross Steph but the woman go mine
crossing her well yeah
step is the famous one I'm just he's
like the legendary one yeah and whether
like it's I don't know if it's an even
mean to say but like she is known and
she has all of her internet followers
because she is his wife
yeah of someone who rose to fame based
off of talent and skill and whatever so
I just thought this is like a ludicrous
thing to say for a million reasons yes
she posted a statement on her Instagram
story like amid all of the backlash I've
never been one to catch my feelings and
emotions to any capacity I am human it
brings me pure joy to speak my mind be
vulnerable at times and to know myself
inside
now seeing as how it's Mental Health
Awareness Month I really want to take
the time to encourage everyone to speak
their truth regardless of perception
fitting into a mold or offending someone
because it's your truth and that's okay
if what I'm not afraid to say out loud
about being a thirty year old mom of
three helps another woman like me feel
like they're not alone not the only
people with an insecurity because we all
have them don't play then that makes all
this hoopla worth it if you get a chance
to watch the actual interview and not
the headlines and rumors please do now
do I get what she's saying and like
that's definitely something relatable
where it's like everyone feels insecure
if like someone doesn't look at you in
the same way but I just think the way
she phrased it like makes no sense like
comparing it to how women throw
themselves at Steph because you can't
even compare like you are famous for
being married so who the hell would come
for you you're married right it just
it's but like I get the meaning behind I
get what she's saying which is like okay
maybe whether how I like how I feel may
or may not make sense but it's how I
feel so I said how I felt right and now
is she's getting backlash because there
was make sense yes oh she was making
some good points in this argument like
women who have no respect for marriage
are the devil totally agree it's
sometimes nice to feel wanted even if
you're married but to compare it to the
way that it's just I'm not I just think
she worded it kind of oddly yeah but I
commend her for being brave and no I she
weren't it kind of oddly but I commend
her for being candid and not filtered
and trying to find the right way to say
it because she's just saying how she
felt right you know and like that's kind
of like now she probably won't do that
again anytime soon like that's sad
because like we should all be able to
speak our minds whether and you know
most of our feelings make no sense
everyone should be able to speak their
minds but other people should also be
able to disagree with it in a humane way
for sure and we're being humane but like
apparently there was a lot of social
media backlash so like I'm sure it was
it was inhumane attack oh no I'm sure
I'm just saying like I feel like I am
really I can really get behind the idea
of like you know civil discourse and not
everyone in the world is can agree on
something that's totally fine and we
live in this great free society where
everyone can explain themselves but like
people take it so far to the point where
it's like we either have to agree or not
talk yeah okay this story are you ready
this is a big one this is the dinner
table conversation for the weekend
because Facebook co-founder has written
an op-ed saying that Facebook has become
too powerful and quote Zuckerberg
powerful is power is unprecedented
and unamerican chris hughes spoke out in
the searing new york times op-ed on
thursday we just briefly pause and talk
about how there's another co-founder of
Facebook yeah it was um he was his
roommate who was he okay oh I don't know
in the movie I only saw the movie once
it was a long time ago me too but like
you told me everything I needed to know
Mark Zuckerberg is a thief
yes co-founder of Facebook blasted the
comment armie hammer is hot as hell
sorry and called for antitrust action
did he play to twins yes Wow like
Lindsay Lohan no oh
like Lisa Kudrow like gillies said CEO
Mark Zuckerberg power is unprecedented
and on American he lamented that
Zuckerberg unilateral control over
speech and threat of censorship he
demanded that federal regulators break
up Facebook into smaller companies
Facebook owns Instagram and whatsapp
which Hugh says should be sold the
company says breaking up and then
Facebook Facebook's response to all of
this said that breaking up a successful
American company is not the solution I'm
sorry hold on take a break I just
thought of my Housewives tag line okay
because I'm really like I'm just sitting
here thinking about how like I feel like
I disagree with like a lot of the
world's opinions but I'm so like normal
in the way that I like engage with
people and like and I really listen to
what people say and like I I don't I
don't stand firmly on issues like if you
want to persuade me like I can be
persuaded I feel like I'm the definition
of civil discourse yeah I put the civil
in civil discourse it would make more
sense if I was like a lawyer or
something but so yeah I think it's a
good start to my Housewives like tag
line I think okay I put the civil civil
discourse or you be like I put the dirty
and dirty yeah that would be like more
person into the current situation yeah
anyways this is like a big this is a big
statement I've been seeing it everywhere
this morning so I thought we might talk
about it now here's the thing I remember
learning about like the antitrust laws
and I remember even back then I didn't
slam out there it's like when companies
become private companies become like too
big and they form monopolies and they
have complete control over like one
aspect of the government can step in and
break them up like - book a private
company Facebook is a public company now
but it's privately owned like it's not
owned by the government and it has
almost complete control over like the
Internet in the media um so like
privately owned companies as opposed
like the government
so what this has happened before like
sometimes when two companies are about
to merge the government has to step in
hey you know or say no because it might
be a company letting too big and it's
becoming a monopoly I know that so this
man is saying that Facebook has not only
monopolized you know the market here but
that Mark Zuckerberg power is at a level
we've never seen before and he gets into
the specifics about the level of control
that Mark Zuckerberg has basically down
to the fact that like he has two billion
people's like news feeds at his hands
and he controls everything that they're
gonna see a choice he decides what is
hate speech Jackie I totally agree no
literally Mark Zuckerberg he must own a
majority stake in glassy-eyed because he
made them a billion dollar company from
their stupid targeted Facebook I said
literally don't stop getting right and
then he made one point that I really
felt strongly about because it affects
like all of us as consumers which is
that there's no space for competition
with Facebook because they either by you
or copying you and put you out of
business and we've seen that so many
times and like I feel like that is one
of the biggest crimes that they've
committed yes the stealing of the story
is the stealing of the videos I totally
I completely agree like what they did to
vine tragedy what they did is snapchat
snapchat they stole their entire
interface totally and like then they buy
Instagram they so if they can't buy you
then they go soppy you yeah and whatsapp
table and like what's up at the time
when they bought whatsapp people were
like ailee's what's up when I travel but
whatsapp has like so many millions of
photos and information like they have so
much information so he's saying that the
government should step in facebook is
say but and now you're gonna punish
Facebook for being a success you know I
don't disagree I see both sides of the
coin so I have absolutely like no
resolution here other than the fact that
it's interesting factoids and I think
that it's really something that's coming
to a head and in our society hmm
like a pimple like it's a pimple yeah
you know I kind of agree but like I also
don't mind do you don't even like I
enjoy Facebook and Instagram and I don't
yearn for any more platforms like as I
can see where do I really care that like
Mark Zuckerberg is so powerful like no
I'm a happy user on Instagram but at the
same time just as like a human being
it's a little scary yeah it's like a
little like intellectual it's a little
black mirror and it's like a bum trying
to launch a platform Mark Zuckerberg is
just gonna buy me okay yeah that's like
if you want to get rich now just like
create something Mark Zuckerberg wants
nobody my
to copy it so that would be like he
tries to buy it first yeah the
Facebook's a try device it's a Faton he
plays her sort of Hartley anyways this
is the talk of the town these days so
it's just a big it is definitely gonna
be a discussion of the gender party this
weekend so I'm really glad you kind of
briefed me on the entire thing yeah but
I don't I don't I don't know how I feel
in terms of like if I were you know what
government advisor I don't know what I
advise them should we break it up
shipping on and if they broke it up like
into what
well the he's saying that they should
definitely break off Instagram and
whatsapp and they shouldn't have that
but but how can you like for someone to
just like like oh it's like letting of
your children yeah just weirder like the
government demand stuff you know yeah
can Nazis like government regulation
yeah it's you know supposed to be a free
country I mean like so you got so
successful and so that so the government
could step in did you um I'm sorry
without a final story I couldn't find
the story I caught up in Real Housewives
of New York and I have a million
thoughts cuz I had to watch three
episodes I don't realize how behind I
really wasn't so I'm sorry if this is
repetitive for anyone but the circus
first of all like Tinsley Mortimer is
the true definition of like fall from
grace like she used to be the talk of
the town socialite Martha Stewart red
carpet every night champagne and like
now that she considers being brought
back into New York society as hosting
the circus for six seconds is horrifying
like all that hoopla with the microphone
the prep to literally do one sentence
like I thought she was gonna be the host
of the night yeah and like then I mean
the breakdown the breakdown like both
people staring at her like the makeup
she looked so dumb but she looks like
she like like lost her mind like a
mental breakdown like must be you know
like locked out and then the next
morning I thought she would be like
honestly I was like so drunk she really
was [ __ ] up yeah I thought she was
like oh I'm like honestly like I'd kind
of feel that way but like I was being
crazy because of the liquor like all she
did was just like make like try and
victimize there's not like no I really
am in this place like your life is so
good [ __ ] like I just can't deal with
people who have obviously like everyone
has their shape but like you have a good
life like you are you are brought back
into society you live an apartment
that's really nice you have a mom and
you're 40 like just be grateful for like
little things instead of like okay you
haven't figured out the whole marriage
thing like you'll figure it out like
just acting like she has a terminal
illness you know no and it's like what
Bethany said a few weeks ago that like
she's really setting women back in the
sense of like she defines success and
Happiness is like on marriage marriage
in like a man's like acceptance of her
where it's like she really and she's
such a great girl so it's like for all
of us it's like why can't you accept
yourself like yeah what what aren't you
seeing and she got a lot of work done
they didn't realize it till they
flashback to the first season she looks
so different yeah I really I really need
her to grow meet you
it's becoming too like now where are
three seasons of stagnation and this is
the time where you grow and like I need
it to happen because I'm getting
frustrated especially like watching like
I have I have so much sympathy for
people and patience and time but like
you are a grown woman with the world at
your fingertips like figure out how to
make it work melissa quirk I made a
really interesting call and she was like
I think a lot of the reason why the
women of housewives get divorced a lot
is because they spend all these years
like being a wife like shacked up in the
house like just doing wifey things and
then they feel this liberation like
being you know their own person and more
independence and and I feel like the
inverse is happening with with Tinsley
where it's like she's waiting for a man
to give her that independence she's like
my life can start once a at the man but
it like no you're started like you have
a business now like you're famous like
do that and the other stuff will come
yeah um when what I thought about when I
was falling asleep last night is how I
really feel like Bravo got ahead of
themselves giving Bethenny a spin off
when she was getting married and having
a baby because like I couldn't have
cared less about her back then but when
she was doing all the stuff about
selling the company like I found that
wildly interesting and I would have
loved like a 30 minute episode a week
about her business I thought the exact
same thing I was like there's only two
interesting storylines happening this
season and one of them is just Bethenny
in the back of a car yes and it's like
where is she going with a paparazzi
waiting for her at Supreme Court I
didn't know that was allowed right like
who are these people buying her business
I've got to know what they're how much
you're buying it formed did it go
through I feel like we would have heard
about it yeah I feel like we would have
heard about it also
maybe she changes her mind I just her
facial I want to hear about her skin
like now is the time where I find
Bethenny to be at her most interesting
and they don't think she has the
bandwidth to take on another show but
I'm just putting it out there that I
would love like a shark tank version of
Bethenny's life you know yeah just like
her filling the tank and like you know
or like a unfortunate Vanderpump rules
her and her girls in the business and
like how what's going on in the business
yes
that's getting girl genes quick QVC did
she run in the center drawer right
Bethenny's business and then also all of
the relief like right and then that
would just be a great platform for like
people to contribute and learn about
what she's doing yeah I forgot that the
custody stuff came back when Dennis
overdosed because he thought that she
was doing drugs too like whatever but I
just found her storyline to be wildly
interesting and you know what I find to
be interesting about this franchise more
so than the others it's like none of the
women prioritize filming they always
stop by the Ramona going to her dates
like Barbara garner her lunch like
everyone like just it's like [ __ ] that
tells the producers to [ __ ] off you know
hey guys I'm here there are less like um
producer organized events yes like
everyone just like stops by and goes and
it's hard to like make drama happen when
they're all missing each other like
Bethenny shows up just as we're gonna
sleeping yeah but I think it's also
because there's they yeah they all have
they're all flip in torrents and like
the most goes out in New York like I
feel like there's way more going on in
New York nightlife then even like
Beverly Hills just because it's like
it's the type of town yeah well if you
want to hear from the women of New York
personally you can because Bethenny's on
cammy oh my god there are so many
housewives I'm counting out waiting one
of the toasters got one from Sonja and
they used our code and I guess she was
in the green room and watch happens live
Andy Cohen popped in so they got like
Andy Cohen cameo like at a reduced price
and that could be you if you use cameo
not only is cameo just a great get for
everything it is a great Mother's Day
gift truly and especially a great
last-minute Mother's Day gift cameo is
wonderful you can they have hundreds of
celebrities that you can choose from to
record a personalized message for you I
am one of them switches one of them Ben
is one of them and it's just like such a
fun personalized gift get someone's
favorite celebrity to just you know give
them a shadow you can tell them exactly
what you want them to say you want to
say good morning Millennials if you
wanted them
Soniya to say we always have the
greatest time I was watching snitch when
we were in somewhere
Baltimore were doing her cameos and she
was being so [ __ ] cute oh my god
she's so cute so here are over 10,000
slides on cameo yeah
visit cameo calm to receive 20% off any
cameo by entering our promo code toaster
your mom will be so shocked she will
freak out for Mother's Day she'll never
expect a personalized video from a slab
there are so many amazing stars on cameo
comm over 10,000 everyone will be able
to find the perfect person for their mom
for Mother's Day it's just it's a great
gift and it's it's so fun to make and
it's so fun to receive you know what
else is a great gift
tickets to the Georgie and sir I'm just
putting it out there oh I I concur when
people come to me and green they're like
this was my Christmas gift remember
thinking if I'm like that is so sweet
yeah that's thoughtful is that and that
makes me feel like incredibly cool
that's like your version of cameos so
then this week on why on New York what
happened oh the charity event oh my god
birdy Bridey are you've dead okay also I
want to talk about during this apartment
for a second I feel stuck with that
after I was dead that conversation was
so horrible you know so horrible about
it I didn't know who was right and who
was wrong they were all wrong because
Dorinda my ragging it all I'm like
you're in dallisa most wrong but there
was a beach and watch happens live who
was the most wrong Dorinda Ramona or
Sonja Sonja everyone voted Ramona so I
think Dorinda was most wrong the way she
literally wouldn't let it go then like
even Ramona was like stop stop but
Ramona should have like shouldn't have
interjected and been like such a [ __ ]
in public which I get but torino was
wildly out of control and it was wrong
yeah it was up she's not drinking so
uncomfortable horrible all right 30
frames she's not drinking and then she's
drinking the rest of the season and like
there's no like you know a discussion to
the viewers right yeah I I want to also
talk about Ramona at that at that event
where the table 61-62
oh my god wait I am loving that the
storyline of Ramona being a social
climber has come back around because
it's so true and she's so not discreet
did she forget she was Mike to that
event when the woman's like 62 I might
at the same table as her own during that
yeah should I invite Sonja no like she
must have forgotten that she was Mike
because she's so blatantly lying I feel
like she thinks like no one's gonna know
cuz we didn't feel it angel ball because
they didn't really feel but I guess she
was just wearing a mic she's so silly so
and I feel actually she learned less she
realized she was wearing a mic at that
dinner where they said should be invite
Sonja because she didn't say no she just
moved her head she didn't realize there
was a camera yeah and like there's that
I forget who told me this but like
someone was once explaining to me like
the dynamics of the Housewives like in
real New York society like not as it
pertains to the show and it's like
Ramona runs in this like very rich elite
crowd and Dorinda is considered to be
like her trashy drunk friend that's what
someone told me so I kind of get why
like she would want to go stay with
Lucia and not have her table also feel
like Ramona isn't you know one for like
details into her like 61 and 62
- like it's I don't think she thought
she was lying I think she heard 62 that
sounds like and then no or like see
normally I would agree with you but the
lady that she wanted to sit next to was
like is it she we're doin ramona center
is there a seat at your table so she
knew the seat she was going to was in
her table I think I've known 61-62 but
she knew the seat where she wanted to
say it was not her table cuz she said is
there an extra seat there oh they're
like oh they're not coming Jenna's Bossa
or whatever got it you know hey yes and
then also it happened for her birthday
party that was so funny that was so
funny but I was confused so that parties
in New York and so she's saying she's
going to Luann's a day later because
that's what her party is oh I guess oh
but you know what Dorinda was making
some Jurina is your camille Grammer
because as much as I think she think the
same thing she was making excellent
points like a birthday parties are for
12 year olds having 100 different
birthday parties like have a dinner and
go to upstate yeah no fifty we're
setting the time like she's saying what
needs to be said the other 50% I'm like
why you should know she's coming she's
the Camille Grammer wait back to the
circus episode she was thirsting so hard
I bet you next season she gets the
circus thinking she wanted it so badly
and I mean on the one hand like that's
like so rude it's her friend's
opportunity at least she wasn't like
trying to hide the fact that she was
jealous no and you know in the morning I
think about it she would have been so
good and it she was and she looks like
the woman who was the actual she's never
going to the big app pay the same air
she should have a residency also I we
talked about the circus the other day
but I never realized it was I didn't
even know like it still happened in New
York and that it's like such a thing so
Ben's mom went she loves like animals
she like loves the circus and I like
told her I literally couldn't go because
the animal thing makes me so sad and she
was like explaining to me how they're
like rehabilitated rescue animals and
just it didn't make it better for me did
she have a good time so I did know that
it was in this circus yeah okay but like
this circus like I never even get like
you know email newsletter it's like
what's going on in your city circus
Lincoln Center like it was a big deal
yeah I want to shine fight to rayna's
new apartment and the conversation that
her and her daughter had in that old
apartment like the daughter was so mean
like I totally understand what they were
saying like we moved move to a new
apartment like right when Daddy died
like you associate grief with certain
places and like you pigeonhole yourself
like in your room and they got what they
were saying like she was like making she
was being so dramatic and like making it
seem like her mom like literally Grey
Gardens to her in this apartment house
she had a terrible childhood like sit on
the cast I already don't like the
daughter I don't like the way she talks
and I'd like that she's filming less and
less
but I was just like felt so bad for
Dorinda she was like well we grew up
here weird is like no I was a grown up
like I was an adult no one it's like so
they lived in the apartment before they
moved in with Richard and then they
moved back so like because they moved
back and I guess that affected him in
some way it negated every single
positive memory that they had in this
apartment up until the day she moved out
like right now that no that's not ever
work and I think like I could tell she
was like really offending her mom yeah I
mostly I made this like a safe space for
us like the were like our world fell
apart and like this was our safe space
and like I was like it was how she
thinks so insensitive like I couldn't
believe it
yeah and especially cuz you know that an
apartment means so much to her in there
like she's not even selling it like she
wants to give it to her daughter yeah
sounds like another day like it's New
York real estate like it's valuable it's
good it's a quick paint job yeah I love
her new apartment me too and I know that
building I looked in that building
actually was very by you
oh really yeah Oh tell me what they'll
think I miss I was like close my eyes
when I'm they show that like I didn't
know where we were I'm in the building I
love the new apartment but she's a
person who like brings all of her old
ugly furniture into a brand new pretty
apartment right but I really liked the
windows the views John came over had a
great time of day where it's like blew
out and is like dark blue and it looked
just really nice I like every I say this
every season but like the way she talks
about him and her enemies like I think
they're gonna break up I thought that
that was the first time I thought that
where's like they're gonna break up soon
they're gonna look at all these
interviews and it's like she was telling
her she's gonna bring up yeah but then
also she said something so OnPoint I
felt what actually people might have
thought it was a controversial statement
when she's people shouldn't get married
yeah marriage is for the young where
it's like you're so whole like you're
building you're so hopeful you're
optimistic you see the world in this way
and like you're gonna build your life
with someone else but like when you're
divorced or older and you're thinking
about like getting remarried it's like
you've already built your life someone
else has their life and now you can just
join their lives like without having to
like you know make it all like legal and
entangle and the perfect example of that
is LuAnn like all she cared about was
getting married like not the meaning of
I was just spending your life with
someone right so like all she care about
was the ring the ring the ring and like
didn't care about anything else like
maybe I don't know having a good
relationship or a faithful partner right
and I just I I never really thought
about it or where my thoughts on it but
after jørgen des said that I was like
honestly I feel that you know yeah like
I feel like when you're younger there's
so many like even just logistical
benefits to getting mine
and when you're older like there aren't
those benefits actually become
detriments like yeah you know getting on
someone's health insurance no totally
but I feel as if Madame Paulette gives
great insurance you know I think I think
yeah I'm like maybe she but I keep this
perk of insurance hmm good question I
don't think so but I did he uh no
actually no yeah cuz it's also like kind
of a part-time thing right it's only
like half the year also I'm just
catching up on Halloween so I'm Bethany
looked incredible and when Bethany
couldn't go to Ramona's thing because
you to go to the Fashion Show it's like
please ladies
make way that's why she really needs her
job yeah like I want to see what
happened at the Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show no totally I wanted more
red carpet on the pink carpet I wanted
more of that like not side mater
underboob yeah yeah
she looked amazing and she looks great
at Halloween and I remember that like
week where she was just like banging it
out and I just love for you watching it
um wait what was I gonna say oh and
LuAnn being late LuAnn was wrong about
every single thing that night every
every single thing and while I totally
get why she didn't come out to the party
in what she was performing she should
have had the ladies up to party and
drink before yeah and like the fact that
that's where she's performing like
literally it was a raise like that like
when they were doing the alcohol like
being poured in those dirty plastic cups
I was like I shouldn't be there you
shouldn't be there they were on Molly
when everyone there was on Molly and
like the dancing she was really trying
to be like Erika Jayne yeah and it was
it was great it was so things are
picking up it looks like next week is a
lot more late cuz like that's why the
trips because these women like don't
prioritize like filming together like at
home
the trips is where it all comes to a
head because they're spending more time
together well that's what I was thinking
I'm like these girls have got to go on a
trip because they keep missing each
other so they're going to Lance House
but I think they still like miss each
other at Luann's house yeah because we
two of them were there they saw each
other during this house too but they go
with somewhere where where is it that
you're showing it falls off the chair
Miami okay that's the chair I'm ready me
too
like it's time that they all spend some
time together and sleep in the same bed
yeah and and Duke it out it's it's been
good I've been enjoying it it's like
nothing nothing's happening but it's
just I love the housewives I slept on
something sound like last night there
was no Bravo that I watch on so I
started a new Netflix show but like I
just love knowing I can like come home
and like the Vanderpump pro skits are
waiting for me totally yeah but then
other times it's like I
Oh time and it's like them you missed
three days in a row you miss three shows
and you're just catching up so um okay
so that's what we got for you guys just
another dirty jeans tour reminder all
the shows that are located in eastern
and central time have been on sale and
the west coast show so Vancouver Seattle
Portland San Diego Las Vegas Los Angeles
San Francisco will go on sale in 30
minutes so that's a noon pacific to know
it sorry no I'm sorry all those shows go
on sale at 10:00 a.m. Pacific time
that's one o'clock here girl with no job
calm all the links are my Instagram
Instagram story is if you need to find
it you will be able to find it it's also
in the group thank you guys so much I
heard you sold out Minneapolis already
so thank you guys so exciting them
Beacon Theatre at noon Eastern oh god oh
my god thank you for reminding me that's
actually in 30 minutes Beacon Theatre I
want everyone to get their phone out get
their computer get their mom's computer
Beacon Theater 12 o'clock Eastern Time
New York City January 25th it's gonna be
incredibly [ __ ] late that's so
Jackie's gonna be there I mean
everyone's gonna be there it's the talk
of the town I heard I heard when
Paltrow's coming but I got it off that's
true I heard that too but I heard she
wasn't like she has him a planner so she
can't say where she'll be right that's
the thing that's the thing about
planners you got a plan
thank you guys so much great weekend I
love you Monday noon Beacon Theater
you